Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and today we have stories on confrontations, face offs,
throwdowns all of them leading to a question. This was the title of our show.
What's left when you're right, it doesn't make a lick of sense yet. Well, maybe,
maybe it will when you hear this story. No, I'm afraid not.
Won't get clear to elevate later in a case. Um,
this next story began when one of our former producers, uh, Lulu Miller, uh,
call me up and said, let's just get in the studio.
I want to talk you through something. Okay. Sorry. You just go. Yeah.
So you've been, you've been, you, so, okay.
I honestly don't quite know what we're doing.
I think you're going to tell me about something that you've been wanting to tell
me.
Yes.
I wanted to quickly tell you what the idea is while while I truly like am still
pretty darn confused by it. Okay. Yeah. Gotcha. Okay.
So done. Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
It's about my bike trip across the country.
You say with a certain amount of Chagrin. I don't know.
I guess I just get embarrassed because it sounds like boring, self-indulgent.
Um, now, uh, when I initially talked with Lulu, uh, the,
she was planning to write a book about the story that we're going to tell. Uh,
and I was really there to just to help her sound out the ideas and we were gonna
use the recording as a transcript for her. So I was just doing it, you know,
we were just having a daughter a favor kinda. But then when I heard the story,
I decided a favor over,
let's make this a radio story because it's, it's, it's spooky actually.
Everyone here on the staff who heard it has had that reaction.
And I think it also asks in its small way of really big question,
which is how do you do good in a world that [inaudible]
wow.
So I feel like I went into the trip very confident about where I stood on people
being really sure that inside everybody was like just another good soul.
You know,
everyone has quirks and tics that make them angry or obnoxious or conceited or
depressed,
but that those ticks are just kind of like a good soul trying to like clot its
way through the world and strikes me as one of your primary assumptions about
the world. Just knowing that well what past tense,
something changed on this trip? Yeah,
there was a moment that
I did the bike trip with my friend sue.
So as she explained, um, is an old friend,
they met in college and she says one of the first things that she noticed about
sue was that she would say the most amazing things. Like for example,
she is Korean and she moved to the states when she was 12 speaks English
perfectly, no accent.
But every now and then she has like a language Mashup that is so brilliant
and she doesn't even notice it. One was like I don't, I don't know.
I was just like running around and I was so crackled that I've done little and
it was like, oh crap, these old, that's not a word,
but I know exactly what you mean.
That's crazy and frazzled and actually that's a better word. And then like,
you know, I'm just, I just don't want to like, why is it when I get down,
I like to eat all this grubbing.
I just don't understand what [inaudible] I'm like,
Grub is invented or like my dad is always worrying that I'm just always going to
be trapezing around and Dah, Dah, Dah.
And she meant traipsing Richard Visa is a much better word, like trippy,
using his better. That's like with our whole generation of like low life ae.
All they're doing with trapezing point is a Lulu was drawn to sue.
They became great friends and part of that connection,
this is the key is that they were so different.
She has a very different personality than I do.
Whereas Lulu is kind of your classic optimist sue.
She's a very um,
grouchy and always like frustrated by people and she's really,
really smart.
So she'll like go on the most wonderfully enjoyable rants about people.
So anyhow, they decided to take this bike trip across the country.
They'd actually done one before.
So they knew they could travel together and they obviously knew they had this
difference in personality. Uh,
and in fact as they were biking and stopping all these little towns,
they would sort of joke about it.
She would always yell at me for being what she called an [inaudible],
which is like we ask for directions and then I'm like,
really old man now are you a farmer? Oh, you're a [inaudible].
How does beaver farming work? Oh you and she's sitting there like, Jesus,
we have 3,500 miles ago. Like so,
so charming. They would tease one another,
but then they came to this moment where that difference between them stop being
charming and it got kind of dangerous. Basically.
Long Story Short, a few weeks into the trip,
Lulus front wheels busted and they roll into this town called Pittsburgh,
Kansas. Kind of a small forgotten town in eastern Kansas near Missouri.
There is nobody there. It was like all desolate and hot,
but there was a bike shop.
So we went to the bike shop and the bike mechanic there, Roger, big ball guy.
I was like,
well I don't have any wheels but I can build you one if you guys can stay at a,
I could build you one today and have it free tomorrow.
So they went off checked email, set up camp,
came back early the next morning we got there and you could tell he hadn't even
started it.
The wheel was just hanging there where they'd left it and Lulu says at this
point her and sister going in opposite directions.
So I registered that and I was like,
maybe it only takes an hour to make a wheel and he'll have it ready by 11 you
know, and sewer registered that and it was just like,
what the f? She said, I'm going to talk to this guy.
I immediately got like hot and flushed and didn't want her to say anything.
Lulu rushes sue out of the store telling Roger, well we'll come back soon.
Two hours later they return again and the bike wheel is still there.
Not even touch.
Sue really wanted to say something and I think we kind of had a skirmish in the
back. Like, I was like, well, don't like,
I could tell he was kind of not taking us seriously, but I still was like,
if we continue to be nice to him,
what reason would he have to like sabotage us or,
or not follow through? If we just keep treating him with respect,
he'll treat us with respect.
And she says, sue on the other hand was like, Lulu, don't you see like,
this guy thinks we're just like these dilettantish college girls.
Uh, he said some weird power thing. He's taking advantage of us.
And he was like, no, he's not.
And then his like stupid is Roger gonna make a bike wheel turned into the
[inaudible] test. Yeah. Turned into like a test of the human spirit. Yeah.
Pass Lulu and sewer sitting on this couch in the back of the store,
not talking to each other.
And um, and then his two little boys come in,
he has two little boys and they were like, Daddy, can we go soon? And he's like,
oh, I got to finish this, but then we can go on the ride. And, and I remember,
I remember that. I remember he called them sweetie.
And I remember that being like a point for me cause I was like,
Oh man, who calls his little boys sweetie? Like that's a good person, you know,
few more hours pass.
And they're still sitting there on this couch now with these two little boys,
all four of us on this couch. And they were watching Nickelodeon cartoons
and in the middle of the cartoons, Gordon Lou,
there was a commercial for the army, like in a recruiting ad.
And she says that that was the moment where sue just
lost it.
She turned to Lulu and maybe it was one sentence and maybe it was 45 minutes
like I don't know. But she said,
you know something along the lines of the way you think you are in the world as
like so nice to people. That's a form of deceit.
And then she says, sue stormed right up to Roger
and I'm sitting on this couch fuming and she laid into him,
we're not going to make it by dark and we have to get there and this is your
fault. And she like demanded that.
One of the like younger guys that worked in his store give us a ride and he's
like, well, this guy, he's got things to do.
And it was just this horrible thing that I was just like,
and on my way out after suit already walked out,
I tried to say something to Roger like, Hey, I'm really sorry. I just,
it's been a, you know, I tried to kind of like apologize for her and for myself.
And he was like, well,
tell your friend so sorry to have inconvenienced her baby.
Lulu said that feeling like this guy doesn't know them just now assumes they are
these spoiled college girls that just ate at her. She kept thinking,
I don't get it.
Like if we had just been nice to the guy instead of confronting him,
maybe he wouldn't think that about us making matters worse.
After they left
the bike shop,
they piled into this car and this kid from Roger's bike shop drove them into
Missouri because that's what sue had demanded. And we paid him.
And the kid was really nice, but I just was like,
this feels so like I feel so disgusting being in this car with her.
And it just like the whole thing was awful.
Got to Missouri and I just remember like Missouri passing in a blur of me being
like I am riding with a crazy person.
Like so you feel like suddenly this difference between you guys was serious?
Yeah. And just to walk me through a little bit of a, I mean I have to,
I do have to warn you though. This isn't the moment. This is not the moment,
not the moment. So let me, do you want to tell me about the moment? Yeah,
I want to tell you about the moment really bad. Um, okay. So I was just like,
finish this trip and then, um, we get to Damascus,
Virginia where the Trans Continental bike route that we were riding crosses with
the Appalachian trail.
So it's like in the mountains and the town put this little,
they said they have tons of people coming through.
So they put this free hostel for bikers and hikers, um,
to stay and it's unmanned, no one's there.
It's basically just kind of like an empty house with wooden bunk beds.
You can lie your sleeping bag on and a kitchen.
So we get there and these two appellation hikers are staying there too and it's
just us and them guy and a girl.
The guy she says was maybe 23 brown hair, super blue eyes.
The other hiker,
she's a young girl doing it by herself and we're all talking late and we're in
this like little living room area.
And he kind of immediately jumps into the conversation and just starts like
taking it over with his life story,
which is that he thinks he's a prophet. Um, he has the gift of prophecy.
He also has the gift of extreme empathy where he can come into a room and he'll
be like deafened by all the thoughts he can hear and other people.
And I was kind of like, all right, we've got a nutter,
but I know what he's saying.
And she was like rolling her eyes and then he says,
oh, and you know, I prophesied the Virginia Tech shootings.
And it's like, oh, okay.
So then there's this silence and it's now like 10:30 PM and I don't know what
you say in that moment. I don't, you know,
like I think like in a way make him not feel crazy for that.
It's somehow in that moment, my instinct is like,
just don't rattle this guy maybe.
And then he says, uh, another time,
um, I was getting off from work,
I was walking home from the bus where that he was like,
worked as a chef or you cook it, you know, in a kitchen.
And he was walking home from the bus and he's really late and he said,
and an African American woman came up to me dressed in really like revealing
clothing and turned out she was a prostitute and she offered her services to me
and I said, no. And then blacked out.
And the next moment I came to and I had a knife around her throat.
Whoa.
There's like this pause. And then
I remember just like my heart almost like pounding,
not of nervousness. It was just like, but, but, but, but it just,
I couldn't let him go on this.
Of course she just hurts attacking him.
I had to correct him. I think that's really irresponsible.
He pulled out a knife.
He said he was done to do something and the fact that he just so cavalierly
and I'm like staring at her clenching my teeth. Like, what the are you doing?
Like this is don't behave this way,
but don't behave this way right now with this person. Please.
No, you're wrong. Like if he didn't want to be corrected,
he wouldn't have told that story. She said, [inaudible]
you know, I think this isn't demonic possession. You need to like seek counsel.
You should confront it. You shouldn't talk with therapists at that moment.
Lou says she reached down and hit record on her tape recorder figuring,
all right, if this guy snaps, we still have it on tape for the police.
You'll hear his voice in here, but we've concealed his identity and he's like,
Oh, what? I'm crazy because I have like influenced by other things.
And she said, you know, you never know the word schizophrenia.
I'm amazed that they've developed schizophrenia. Yeah, I know it's a big word,
but it's a psychological issue. You do.
I do remember he was like, no. He's like, you're calling me schizophrenia. No.
So typically you would go to that and she is just like taking him to town and
they're fighting and I'm scared because then we'll all have
[inaudible] problem. We just kept arguing and I'm like, why?
What we trying to get from this guy to admit that I almost killed someone.
I almost killed someone, period.
That was me, but it wasn't. She was just like, but why are you telling us this?
You come out, you show us your journal, you tell us this story.
We've known you for three seconds.
You clearly want to be judged and so I have to judge it.
Of your laws or the Bible, which seems to be what you rely on,
say to respect the laws of the land. How dare you take like a life,
a human sacred life, you know, in your hands, you know,
almost more than a black woman. That's scary to me.
And the fact that you won't confront that as that is even worse.
You almost did that. And she like,
I don't know, I had this moment like suddenly
there you go. They just [inaudible]
Lulu says she's not sure why,
but it turned
even if it's still,
and I was like, I am so like
proud to be associated with somebody like this. Like I am.
I would never do any of that.
And she just like knows how to stand up for things. Um,
and it turned for him too.
He kind of like over time slowly started backing down and even conceding,
I really might need help and I don't know how to get it.
And then she sort of softened and they were really having a conversation and
this thing inside him, like
a different him came out like not the weird, crazy person.
And I was just tolerantly accepting like I have a little being,
a real confused person came out and was talking to her, you know,
and everyone else kind of dropped away and,
and they like go out and share this cigarette on the porch and come back
literally like arm, like arms slung over each other. Okay.
I think when you get to the bottom of something with someone,
you feel a kind of kinship. Right.
You know,
I don't know what they set out there and all I knew in the moment was like,
I am so proud of her. I am so like proud to be with this person.
Like I realized that she has so much,
she just has so much more hope.
Like she is just raged by anyone who doesn't like live up to their potential.
Like I don't, it's like my little theory was like, oh,
we're all just selfish and we all kind of are assholes, but we're all,
you know, but be nice about it. And, and she like,
has this a true hope like that actually we could that actually like we're
capable of have better
you [inaudible]
I,
that's a really utopian reading of such a crappy pot part of my personality.
Seriously. Like you can't even give me that. Like,
is there really no part of you that sees what is so good about this?
The reason why I say it's Romanticizing is that it's actually, it's the kind of,
um, you know,
it's like scratching at a scab or something and that's what I tend to do and
it's hurtful for the parties involved and it's, it's, it's alienating to me,
right? Nobody wants to be around that person. Um,
but the change you create on the other side, I mean, it's change.
It's like my way of being maybe feels good in the moment and it enables stasis,
you know, but it also sustains, right.
A relationship. Right. Let me ask you this. Have you had issues with
being cruel to friends and losing friends or something?
And I'm just guessing based on what your, what you just said? Yeah. Yeah,
I think so. Um,
yeah,
sue actually said that when she got home from the bike trip,
her roommates at the place where she was staying confronted her. Um,
we think you have an anger problem. So I just, I, I moved out.
There was a big blowout fight and then I moved up.
So the story leaves you with some questions,
like if you agree that people are messed up, like of course they are.
We all are. And what's the best way to heal people? I mean,
do you decide as Lulu does or did that you should approach world with kindness
and happiness no matter how the world greets you?
Or is that kind of giving up like a happy hopelessness?
So then do you put your foot down as suit did and say, no,
you are messed up. Don't be messed up.
Is that hope or just being mean? I
don't know. I don't know. I don't know.
I'm still confused. I'm still very confused.
Maybe I have it all wrong.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thank you, Lulu. Thank you, sue. Thank you. Jad thank you.
Big thanks to Damiano Marchetti we'll be right back.
[inaudible].